rock and roll tonight and I have a
feeling it's gonna happen who would we
say is most likely to be delivered fun
and fun to hang out with and get drunk
I'm hoping that Kim Petrus and Sam Smith
are going to be hanging out right we
love I think they're going to probably
Rock a few feathers with their
performance one would hope right yeah
what would you make of a controversy
going into this the fact that it's
another male best artist
assistant
we're still not there yet but I do think
that it should be a non-binary Academy
maybe there's even more people being
able to be within within that category
and there are some amazing girls
but of course we can always do better so
I hope we just diversifies and
diversifies and yeah who are you hoping
for a selfie with tonight I want to sell
I mean I wouldn't say no
after transporting the bodies of his
uncle and his other cousins to be buried
crushing Lee sham later died in the
hospital
[Music]
three sisters one found dead one found
alive and one still buried
horror happiness and then heartache all
in one day
Sky News
well that's the aid effort to help the
Quake fiction gathers Pace our
correspondent Ashner huronag has spent
the day with the charity is going teams
of international response
these volunteers
that they know so positive you know we
need so much Veterans
Services
but they all have a unique skill set and
a design to help obviously Kim
petrasound I loved Harry's albums so
incredible performer so Harry my friend
Reena
yeah just looking forward to seeing
everyone win really
so we can help facilities
yeah as a former Army medic and now
nurse Sarah still can tell your girl
with this because after this devastation
we're currently traveling with our type
1 facility to be able to support
delivering Primary Health Care and where
it needed most dangerous thing turkey
this has affected over into that Syrian
side as well
and it may be at some point the
conditions are set to enable us to go
across now for now they are all
providing a Lifeline to Turkey that this
team aren't rolling out cropping into
Syria we've got to be pragmatic about
this there are thousands of people
hundreds of thousands of people who need
help and we've got to look at where we
can get too quickly and then have an
immediate effect
considera is much more challenging there
are lots of people who need help there
we will start to reflect now on whether
we can shift our attention in that
direction but not until we've got this
line going and we know we're helping
people in need when disasters hit and
take bravery Beyond Comprehension to run
towards for danger that they know their
presence could be invaluable
well in other news this evening the fire
brigades Union has recommended its
membership sector revised pay offer
Computer Services literally the unions
the new payoffer for a seven percent
rise backstated to July last year and
for another five percent increase from
July this year was below inflation but
still represented what is called a
significant shift from a previous offer
of just two percent
you're watching Sky News coming up we'll
get the latest on the rescue effort in
Turkey for my correspondence
sorry oh I thought it's been helpful why
not that's good
[Music]
can you get that down Jason
I undo it and then I can't figure out
how to do it up again
right
can you just hold up
[Music]
foreign
sometimes
okay
so Gemma just needs to be able to earwig
I'd say just be somewhere and we'll fit
around your gym
[Music]
yeah yeah they looked great they were so
good weren't they and with the music in
it
that's amazing
yes
[Music]
search and rescue operations continue
across turkey and Syria with research
still on for survivors traps under the
rubble our correspondent Siobhan Robbins
is the latest now from karaman Marsh
from in Karama marash at six days after
this earthquake and I'm talking quietly
because if we spin round you can see on
the mound behind me yeah
you have the most chance of surviving
they haven't given up a hoop here and
what we're seeing here is being
replicated Street off the street in the
city
with rescue teams continuing to search
through the rubble and although that
initial window has closed we are still
hearing of amazing stories of people
being rescued five members of the same
family in gaviant sneakers here earlier
in the week two sisters
[Music]
throughout to that'll be experiencing
the level of success that you've got it
must be incredibly rewarding for you
guys to stick true to your morals and
what have you at your belief yeah
yeah definitely I think um we've always
just thought this kind of stick to your
past questions
especially over High ground but the
Southeastern half of England got
slightly overcast
nearer average in the southeast
colorful dress however they want to
dress
and especially like an old scene as well
it's like guitar music was so popular at
that point seven years so it's coming
back again and we want to hear Heavy
Music we want to see musicians share
playing live and you know that's that's
our field and we're so glad it's here
like one of the bands are here today you
know so it's fine and while women are
absent from the best artists category I
mean you guys are here sort of
representing for the women aren't you
how do you feel about that little bit
guys
this is the ISB circuit the sky
newsletter
right
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ifb circuit Sky News London
this is the ifb circuit for Sky News
London
is the ISB circuit
Sky newsletter
this is the ISB circuit Sky newsletter
you hear better is that okay this is
the sky in New Zealand
yeah this is right
so we'll stay
um yes
I'm also about to do a lie but
uh 5 40 but I'm optimistic I might be
able to be able to do them quickly yeah
I wouldn't mind but I
know nominated
uh not hearing anything at the moment
but they might be on a break
[Applause]
[Music]
no
problem
[Music]
it's not that bad yeah
would it be
foreign
[Music]
are you hearing anything
are you hearing anything or are you not
going to hear anything
I think we're going to break stuff
[Music]
hello again over 25 000 people have been
killed and eighty thousand injured in
turkey and Syria after Monday's
catastrophic earthquake dozens of Agents
have deployed to respond to the disaster
including the injured and supporting the
millions of people who've been left
homeless among the groups providing
Medical Care is humanity and inclusion
UK and joining me now from Amman and
Jordan is their Syria program director
Miriam Goldman thank you so much for
talking to us
just give us an idea of of what your
charity is able to do in Syria at the
moment
please
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
right the only way YouTube are happy is
if I I don't have clean fee going into
my camera so that I can hear it okay
um
foreign
[Music]
I'm sorry they might be Crossing to me
live in about five minutes time if Rina
happens to be here as well as she up for
doing something live brilliant yeah
brilliant thank you regardless we want
to know though yeah
It's Tricky for a live for the same
reasons if she comes up during my life
[Music]
is people
they've spoken to me so yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
5 48 okay
oh okay
[Music]
um
[Applause]
Ashley should we do this regardless as
an aslive and they can just turn that
around couldn't they if we started
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
so
much
two reasons
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
sorry that's all right they're very
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
um I received a phone call and I was
very excited it is different for me
because
um you know I wouldn't have been
eligible for this award and three years
ago when I applied to be eligible for
the Brits and mercuries I was told that
I couldn't because I didn't have a
British passport and um through
campaigning through social media I was
able to have a really really great
conversation with the Brits and BPI and
they changed the rules and now I'm able
to be nominated alongside other people
other immigrants who wouldn't have had
this voice and it feels really really
good
I mean how frustrating must that Journey
have been for you along the way then
does it I I guess the struggle that
you've had to get nominated does it kind
of sum up the argument we're all having
that perhaps these sort of categories
they do require some tweaking to get
right sometimes yeah definitely and you
know what
it's really easy to go from a place of
hate I think and to think that there's
bad intentions behind everything and of
course it's sometimes there is but often
it's just an oversight and it's just
people figuring things up and I think
that conversation is really really
important and also I believe this just
in daily life you've got to come from a
place of understanding don't understand
why they did that and whether they are
capable of understanding that there's a
mistake been made and then just move on
move forward you know I it's really
um important to me that the conversation
about gender is not hurt by the fact
that you know there's not been enough
female and non-binary artists and it's
all male this year yes I mean when you
saw that you are you Theory would be
eligible to
Quantified
well
let me break it down this way right we
combine two two categories and put them
into one but then kept the same number
of nominations and I think that is the
main problem because to be realistic
like I'm always like the Brits you know
it is a lot of it's based on commercial
sales and some years like men are going
to do better in commercial sales than
women and that's just going to happen
maybe some me as women will do well and
um it's just it's important as you know
a Awards body to recognize that you need
to have enough number of nominations so
that that
does not exclude the fact that just you
know commercial sales were dominated by
men or whatever does not exclude women
and non-winary people and I do not want
this to affect
for people to be like well this is why
you shouldn't combine and this is why
two genders as well like that's not the
issue it's easy you just gotta saw it
you just gotta have more money more
nominations and you will get the
diversity
sorry
still nobody's speaking to you
I had a ginger shot earlier
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
at least we're doing here
yes hello
how are you Crossing to us
oh
I got told
yeah we're here I got I'm told we were
biffed but yes fine
[Applause]
I might kind of get you to look around
then
yeah
go home
yes I am yeah
I am yeah
okay
yep fine
how short is short
[Music]
thank you
can't really show you can't do a cutaway
that way can you
it's more of Arena that I wanted but
thank you
what about the
the um
Prosthetics
this is very quick
thank you
okay
that's fine don't worry we weren't
expecting you to
no time
[Applause]
working out
who was witness went like a right there
we care about these guys
[Music]
okay
yeah
[Music]
very excited
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
no what like you can get them yes please
absolutely
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
today
it's so exciting yeah I can't remember
vibrations
Our Lives
[Applause]
were you able to grab them off I think
we might have to scoop around uncle Ryan
out of time together
[Music]
very angry yeah we hate each other we're
not getting along on tour at all it's
really difficult
but some people what
uh we think they're going to win
everything
and we hate Harry Styles
joke check joke
I don't know it's pretty inconceivable
and like
if this is the top
then we should probably quit hearing
actually just stop now like quit whilst
we're heads
about the writing process as well
am I right because
we're trained to the people who are
taking the seriously
ah
chainsaw is a really serious song and
wet dream as well
from that the rest of it is
a bit uh I'm listening to an artist
called Hemlock Springs
she's only got three songs out
but they're all bangers
and then in the dressing room earlier we
were playing Fantasia and
the audience
yes it is different because at a gig you
like people have four tickets and you're
kind of like on a mutual like playing
field it's like we agree to be here and
you guys agree to be here whereas this
is much more of like a
I don't know
it's just but yeah it's different but
it's fun to experience this madness this
escape room situation
we will make it out alive I predict
thank you very much
uh just that they didn't take it
themselves very seriously when they were
writing it or one of them says
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
um
another thing
I'm sorry I meant your
s
[Music]
yeah
hey hello hello can we just grab you
guys this area how are you best
International it's a good one to be
nominated yes
I mean crazy competition uh just very
rewarding to be in this list and to to
see all the music I mean on the on the
way over here I checked all the tracks
one more time I was like these are
pretty much so yes I think we're just
super happy to be here to be able to
enjoy this evening and let's see how
it's going to happen yeah 100 it's not
even more surreal the international
aspect of this award you're up against
like huge yeah it was so funny when I
told my friends that it was the
international category they were like
Halls International and I was like no
Felix is from Belgium that's why it's
International but you know what I think
yeah probably there is a little bit more
um there's a there's a huge amount of
talent because it's from all over the
world isn't it it's like there's the
Brit Awards and then the international
one
um but in fact being named alongside
Beyonce and Liza and Encanto and
Taylor Swift just to name a few it just
reminds you that you know where where
our names have been at the same category
as those guys so just really proud and
and and and standing here with a good
friend and celebrating what this song
has done is the best thing in the
recording I mean what was the vibe like
then I was I was going to release the
demo because it was so good we had he
had to stop he was like stop stop stop
let's we record the vocal but uh yeah I
was really hyped to work with Callum on
this track yeah yeah it was it was
really funny
um my I was I was I'd recorded the
vocals for Felix and I was playing it to
my friends and I said you know like oh
like I'm usually the guy that sings the
ballads and you know what if people
don't like me singing dance music I
showed it to my best friend Jess and she
said if you don't release this song
we're no longer friends
so I've got my best friend to thank
there's just blackmailing me
um but now we're celebrating her Britain
nominated songs so that's what best
friends are for
she's not it's like gold dust getting
these tickets so I'm just happy I'm with
it
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
very quick so they can I assumed they
couldn't but they can
put they can put stuff up
no that's uh
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
yourself
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
if I imagine
it's reflecting the time
for me
having an actual three days
thank you
[Music]
all right do you guys want Fireboy DML
you don't have to probably not so it's
nominated
sorry
[Music]
thank you
that's Jessie J down there
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
.com
because
here
you come here
[Applause]
oh thank you so much
thank you
yeah I guess I guess you know but it
kind of becomes like a an award who has
the most followers but I'm here for it I
appreciate it
yeah I went to the thing that means the
most with the name Brits is the Brit
school you know I went to the Brit
school and and I had a beautiful time
there you know I was offered a space to
fail like in in in a safe space you know
to learn what it is to create and and
not feel pressure so yeah I owned a Brit
school you know and it teaches there
Stuart Warden the heads each other and
my bag of my my theater teacher you know
I owe them a lot for sure
Rivals that you're up against tonight I
mean yeah hey I I feel very lucky to be
um you know honored to be you know
acknowledged within that world because
uh I guess I've always felt like a bit
of an outsider within that you know yes
I love rap music I grew up on it but you
know I know my music is you know is
individual to me and and I feel very
warm that instead of making compromises
I was very much myself and have still
found myself within a category that um
means a lot to me so yeah very cool it's
always controversy every year with the
Brits this year it's about the fact that
it's quite a male heavy year
particularly best artist it's all men
how do you feel about it yeah I was I
was just saying that you know I feel
like all Awards and everything in
general we need to just update move for
the times you know if you don't evolve
then you'll come extinct so my point my
like my only thought on it is that my
favorite rapper is little Sims so she's
not here but she should be are you
looking forward
tonight because you're radical probably
um yeah apparently I'm sitting with hu
I've never met so
get ready to be my friend yeah I don't
know
thank you so much thank you so much
there you go
yeah I am the only human life
see I mean if I don't win
my okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
responsibility yeah
foreign
to come naturally and I have to fake my
team it takes a village
It Takes a Minute it takes a village
um
[Music]
I was just saying over there you don't
get many opportunities to be new to be
fresh to still be considered in this
kind of like I'm excited by him
kind of way and um I take honor in that
you know what I'm saying I'm
appreciative this is my first Brit so
technically I'm new here never been here
never smoked the carpet it's nice fresh
Febreze you know what I'm saying and for
me
I represent a lot to a lot of people
because I took a longer route to kind of
establish myself in my career and um and
I like to show younger artists that
there's nothing wrong with developing
with taking your time and never feeling
like age or anything like that is making
you stale or irrelevant or whatever like
just make the best music you can and
you'll always be in there I mean you
start making this last year even more
satisfying than if you'd have kind of
just suddenly found the fame you you
haven't you've stayed true to yourself
100 100 and like I said to myself I'm
going for a clean sweep you know what
I'm saying even before I even knew it
was a possibility to be nominated for
anything I said I'm going for a clean
sweep I wanted
um I wanted a mobile nomination I wanted
a Mercury nomination I wanted
um a rated award nomination and I wanted
a Brit award nomination and I and I
completed the the I completed the
infinity rings
and now snap of the fingers might take
half the awards who knows
exactly that would be so lovely
do you know what is as well
Viola Davis is cold she's the best and
like I love her and any building where I
can be in with her I'm trying to be
there so if there's an acting role out
there for me shout me I'll do it I'll
even be in the well I think top Boy's
over but if they're making something
similar I'll just I'll be humbly in the
back mind minding my business
yeah
yeah who else is in there wet leg Arena
that's our best artist is all men who's
in there
Georgie
yeah
probably Harry or something it's Harry
in it right yeah it's a lot of men it's
a lot of Jesus
[Music]
do you know what it is do you know what
I think happened
because somewhere some somewhere down
the line someone gives them a pattern
someone gives themselves a pat on the
back for what they've done so they go
we've we've nailed it
and what they thought they did was
because there's a category for best
female that was sorted
and then Best New Artist came and it was
like oh we've already kicked the quota
but the Brit Awards represents a lot you
know what I'm saying that in to some
degree it's almost our version of the
Grammy so they they have a
responsibility to do more in order to
make sure more is represented so they
could just split things up this would be
an r b category by itself you know what
I'm saying that best like best hip-hop
gram and rap is the most nonsensical
category title in the world but we're
here I'm not in that category side of
Mind mine's pretty straightforward best
new eyes but I just got here so I can't
really cuss them too much but next year
I would love for them to include more
females and the best artists because to
be honest some of the best team my my
favorite last year were all female to be
fair that one of them's here
that's all thank you appreciate it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
very much
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I'm down here I don't know it's over
here
um are you gonna release a rate of
maternity rate
um you know what I've actually talked
about it a lot with my stylist because
she was pregnant not long ago and there
is a very limited
thing of like this is what you should
wear I don't know maybe
um
I feel like I don't know it's a tough
it's a tough one to answer because
celebrating great music is celebrating
great music whoever that happens to be
um I don't know
I don't know I don't know if they would
be the same conversation if it was the
other way around
so I don't know I think of course women
deserve to be celebrated
I think the best deserves to be
celebrated so if that's I don't know
it's a tough one isn't it because it's
of course yes but
if we do everything based on everyone's
opinion of
that everyone and everything should be
do you know what I'm saying sorry it's a
hard one to answer because I don't want
to seem like I'm not a feminist because
I am but I also just believe that
the best people should be nominated so
it's like you shouldn't put someone in
because of their gender
just because it it you know what I'm
saying I don't know
no I just announced a new song today
called the award goes too so yeah I am
becoming a mother but I'm also still me
um and I want to make sure that I put
out some music soon because it's been
too long
yeah
football team thank you
assistant
[Music]
or something
foreign
[Music]
everything
can we just grab you quickly with Sky
News
[Music]
I'm getting the pity vote thank you
Sky News
it'd just be great together for a couple
of questions if possible yeah Sky News
should we grab you quickly while you
wait until the next time
I
know I know check me out I know I know
about the nominations
I was just in my house my manager was
like you've been nominated this is great
Awards and I was like and he's just like
a very relaxed chilled man he was just
like you've been nominated and I was
like oh okay
um and then he was like oh yeah and
you're performing and I was like wait
what
um so it was a very chilled environment
where I found out
he had been incredibly mad for you I
mean the level of attention that you are
now getting there's sort of other famous
people on here saying
no they have it give over
really who else
right there we go don't tell lies now
oh thank you
yeah it's been it's been mental I mean I
I always just never believe that when
anybody says stuff like that
um because I just have massive imposter
syndrome so I'm just always like how am
I here why am I here
um so I'm trying to like learn to
believe that I'm meant to be here
but it's just it's it's it's a whole
it's a whirlwind
does that make it even more surreal when
you're performing to your peers then I
guess as well we're looking out to the
audience it's going to be definitely
nerve-wracking because it's like people
in the industry that I'll be performing
to as well as like the people at home
um but I use that as kind of like
excitement to try and be like no let's
show people like I'm here
um so I'm excited and I'm nervous yeah
there's always a bit of controversy
surrounding the Brits this year it's the
the sort of quite male heavy uh names
that we've got this year particularly
the best artists it's all men isn't it
this year how do you see the situation I
see it as obviously it's very sad I mean
there's there's so many amazing female
artists
um but I do think with with all that
everyone said and the different opinions
that people have brought I think there
will be there will be
um changes there'll be tweaks and
changes definitely
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome
Gemma
[Music]
foreign
right now
I'm way too long
I'm not sure I'd say no to someone and
now I regret it okay
let me see if we work out for you
thank you
hello can I grab you guys just quickly
I think it's a great celebration so you
know you know British music and and it's
just something that
you know we love together I think you
don't really I think people think that
artists hang out with each other all the
time and we really don't we see each
other once every few years so it's a
real like coming together moment and
like Matthias said a celebration music
I need to have another look I literally
glanced here it's more that I was like
looking at who was performing because
that's going to be really awesome
yes
remember the year he was like
footballing in the rain and all of that
like we want I want to know what he's
going to bring this year
I know
I think you know what I I mean I just
hope I mean I don't know it's it's great
male ice anyway so hopefully yeah and
like to see some women yeah it'll be
lovely too
sit down so it's just five in total
maybe they make it a bigger category
yeah they feel like just even just
removing like the male and female thing
we just want people who have been great
music in the camera and then get awarded
for their work you know I just I love
music in general so
um but hopefully yeah like you said next
year we can mix it up
oh my God there's a lot of festivals
we're actually going to Australia in the
next couple of weeks yeah
we're doing headlining the O2
um 15 for September make sure everyone's
there
it's uh it seems to be snowballing and
going from Center strength and we're
just enjoying every
minute
thank you thank you thank you so much
have a great time
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
possibly about it
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and how long is tight
okay
if we get I'm about to go live but I'll
happily grab him as we're talking
about
hello
[Music]
brilliant okay
lovely thank you
foreign
ER
[Music]
[Applause]
a couple of minutes to us by the way
did you go up Hind s
I don't care if you're not on me a lot
actually
the baby's doing shots as well
yeah
I'll try not to talk yeah okay
laughs
right okay
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
hello look uh it wouldn't be the Brits
without it getting a bit boozy behind me
sugar babes sitting on some little
bottles of alcohol that they've just
been given that kind of sums up the
British doesn't it and if you look fell
down the cut red carpet this way Sam
Rider Eurovision runner-up so it is a
bit of a star started to pair this one
as is always the case with the Brits it
wouldn't be the Brits without a bit of
controversy as we say the best artist
category all male this year you've got
Central C Fred again George Ezra stormzy
and Harry Styles no women making that
list and actually out of sort of over 70
people that would have been eligible
only 12 women were actually eligible and
we managed to catch up with one of those
women a little earlier who would have
been eligible Arena uh sabayama and she
was telling us actually she didn't want
the fact that this controversy to
overshadow the importance of actually
getting rid of the the best male and
best female and having that one category
she's been is an important step forward
that's already been made
thank you
look Sam Smith coming out as non-binary
a few years ago was part of the reason
that category was introduced I urge you
if you get a chance look at the sky news
blog because Sam Smith outfit that he's
worn here tonight it is incredible big
inflatable really one to look out for
he's gonna be performing tonight but
really the man that everyone wants to
see who I believe has arrived but it
hasn't made its way here Harry Styles
will he come away with the uh all four
uh categories that he's been nominated
for will he come away with four wins
he's tied at leading the nominations
with wet leg actually the the band from
the Isle of Wight who are supporting him
it'll be interesting I think given his
Grammy win we are expecting uh Harry
Styles to do very well tonight
thank you
[Applause]
sorry A bit chaotic
[Music]
it's a live Telly for you with the flag
blog mention like on the spot okay
foreign
half of them
[Applause]
I'm stoked oh sorry I am stoked very
stoked
um
yeah I'm going to say stoked again I am
it's going to be fantastic
um I hope I can do can you get tickets
because I'm trying to get some tickets
and
yeah I think I might have to because
there should be like a Eurovision like
Nando's black card where you can go back
if you perform they don't do that but
I'm putting the idea out there
[Laughter]
thank you
[Applause]
um
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
um
oh
thank you
you're right it's it's very interesting
when it's happening and I of course the
best because you I just wanted to open
the discussion
foreign
just sort of going for the women really
tonight sorry
foreign
everybody
[Applause]
Asia
foreign
[Music]
type of
song you know it's the production that
defines it dances it reggae or is it you
know hip-hop you know like in reality I
really think that that good song is a
good song and the way you produce it
defines it in the in a
in a time frame you know and being a
producer I think
success is like
you do something that
has not been done
but still feels a little bit familiar
and it's that balance you know
oh thank you so much thank you thank you
man appreciate it thank you thank you
thank you so much
thank you
foreign
today
thank you
foreign
all right
um
foreign
right now
yeah
I've got like five people
I don't know who she's with
thank you
once they wear her outfits I want to buy
that out
yeah
can I add genuinely can you find out
foreign
conversations
I want outfit Intel where's your outfit
yeah it's the kind of like suppose
they're like almost like loungewear that
you can wear around
the trims and stuff but yeah
I love it
oh God
foreign
from here
is
information
can you think of what grab we want to
use
um
thank you
yesterday
I can't really remember
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
Florida
right there
makes sense
thank you
I've done Electronics
foreign
[Music]
uh yes
yeah
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign
mornings
is amazing
thank you
say that again
it's fine
hello Tyler
um
MTV
can I grab you just
think so what song is living room
as it was by Harry Styles but also wake
me
I know I'm not late on it but for some
reason that's a med right now
okay
Stan what does Stan mean like a bit like
be a fan of the kind of thing collab
50 Cent
stand
I've already got all these old stand
accounts so we'll keep that one what's
the other one
oh Wiz Khalifa
a kid it's a Manchester one yeah any
octopodies tonight
to be fair I'm not saying that there's a
couple options so I don't really know
yet I'm gonna kind of like see
when we're going there in a minute
everyone's gonna be like are you going
to oh are you going to and then we'll
find out that way thank you very much
thank you thank you guys